Okay, listen gents, this episode is probably my favourite. I think it's
probably the most
valuable concept that I can give you in this mini episode. And I guess this is
ultimately
what makes this mini course the most valuable of anything in my personal
opinion. Although
everything else is extremely valuable, this on top is can be gold if it's
applied correctly.
And what I'm referring to is structural invalidation. So the reality is having
a structure OS is
incredibly, incredibly helpful and amazing. But as you evolve and grow as a
trader,
what you want to be looking to do is increase your own ability to read price,
plain and simple.
And there are some situations where even though the indicator will tell you
that structure is
bullish or the structure is bearish, you may want to look at reconsidering. And
there are two
scenarios in which that really happens for me. And that is when Asia high or
low is a swing
point. And when the daily and weekly bias are both heavily aligned against your
idea. And I'll
give you some context on the second one. The first one is really simple. Don't
use Asia low and
Asia high as swing points, especially when they're in tight compact ranges
inside of a price like.
So there are two different areas, you know, you can be inside of a price like.
So if you look at
this, I see this as kind of one price like right from a low to a high. And this
Asia is inside the
price like versus if we were to zoom out a little bit, right? If this was Asia
low down here, that
wouldn't be inside the price like that would be outside the price like it's on
the outside of price.
It's quite clear, obvious and simple, right? This for me would be outside of
the price like,
right? This would be inside the price like, right? Because this isn't really a
price like.
And so yeah, hopefully that makes sense. Right outside of the price leg, kind
of really outside
of the price like these levels. Right, that's why this is Asia high right here.
This level here
is Asia high. But it's outside doesn't get taken. So it's inside the price leg.
And it's your swing
point. It's a dangerous game. And it's something that I've learned through a
lot of experience and a
lot of data collection. If I'm in this scenario right now, I'm looking at price
. What, where are
we? We have we were bearish, right? Break of structure, bearish, break of
structure, bearish,
bullish change of character, pullback bullish, break of structure. So the 15
minute is indeed
bullish right now, we're on the expansion phase. So the 15 minute is bullish.
And the swing low is
down here. This for me is where things get tricky. Because right now, I would
definitely not be
trying to buy at this level. That's the first thing. I would not want him to be
buying in the
market at this price, because this is a massive red flag for me. And so on one
hand, I would want
to be avoiding it. And you can see right price comes into that level has a
reaction price comes
into the level has a reaction. How many traders that don't know this, do you
think that this is
induced, right? We hit in a swing low. It's a swing low, right? We've hit a
bullish water block.
We've had a bullish reaction, right? They're going to try and buy this level.
Big, big mistake.
See it time time again, press will run through. Now what's going to happen is,
well, now the
15 minute is bearish. So now what people might be thinking is, hold on a minute
, let me, you know,
maybe sell this price level. But the problem is, is we're selling based off of
the idea
that this is a good look to use as a measuring tool. And it's not. So for me,
this is what I would
deem a quote unquote fake reversal, right? And it's always usually always the
change of character.
So for example, if you look at price, right, when prices print in market
structure, like so,
you can get times where the market won't agree with your logic. That is normal.
So you'll be
looking at it as, okay, low, high, high, low, high, high, high, high, low, low,
low, ah, bearish.
Oh, wait, what? Higher, high. And in reality, how the market scene price was
low, high, low, high,
low, high. And this in here was invalid, which is exactly what this is in here.
And so it's
always the change of character, but doesn't mean obviously the change of
character is bad. The
change of character is amazing. It's the first sign of the reversal. But when
you combine a change
of character with an internal leg of Asia low or high as a swing point, it's
very easy to be
kind of swayed on the wrong side. And so you might have taken a loss trying to
be a buyer here.
And now you might be trying to be a seller of price. Now you might try to be a
seller.
And again, at that point as well, you might very well get induced into price.
And you can see price
doesn't take out the low. It holds the previous low and then expands and takes
out the high
and continues, right? And then we continue bullish from that level.
And so yeah, right, there's another perfect example. I've seen this instance,
we do just
continue trading lower. But ultimately, you want to be cautious when you have
internal Asia,
any high or low, that's supposedly a swing point. And you're expecting to trade
from it,
I'll tell you through experience that it's probably not going to be the best
decision for you. Because
you can see a lot of the times London sweeps Asia, sweeps the other side of
Asia, London sweeps
Asia, sweeps the other side of Asia. It's a very common mechanism. So that
would be my first
kind of invalidation logic is depending on the situation, depending on the
situation.
This is why I think data and experience is very important. I say inside a
prosperity school,
I have, I don't know, like hundreds and hundreds, probably close to 1000 trades
live executed at
this point, like me recorded the video of the trade playing out. And through
that, you get to
see the experience of understanding which highs hold, which highs don't, but
mainly the invalidation
logic is first and foremost, the Asia model. The second one actually comes from
the trade I mean
today. So today, right now, I am actually in short positions, which you
probably already know,
because I already said it a couple of different times in the other episodes.
But as I write now,
I'm in shorts and so are, you know, a decent amount of the prosperity school
students.
And this was the first take profit. And now we've closed that take profit. And
I'm ultimately
holding some partials down to here. I think the price might be able to make its
way down here.
Now, why the invalidation logic in this scenario, because it's nothing to do
with Asia,
but it's everything to do with the directional bias of price.
Right. So again, remember, I said it's always the change of characters usually.
So there's a couple different schools of thought here. Right. The first one is,
if we look at the weekly timeframe, right, and this is the data that we have
that backs up this
hypothesis. When we get this, when this, so this is the previous week's price
action,
we closed below the previous previous week's law. And so based off of that
information,
we already have the data, the actual data over, I don't know what this is, like
15 years of data
that tells us that there is a 68% chance that we will trade into this law, a 68
% chance that
we're going to trade into this law. Right. So that's the first thing. We have a
very clear,
bearish expectation. In fact, a 68% chance likelihood. And what happens as well
,
as someone who this is just pure data, right, as someone who has been in this
market now for,
you know, heading into my sixth year, I can tell you that this is pure
mechanical data.
There is also the art of understanding price. And then my internal operating
system
that sees certain scenarios that can better predict than even the data could
itself.
And so I, this for me, because of how I within set up a moment or too much
detail,
but because of how it's set up, I deem it as a more than 68% chance of hitting
this law.
I'm more so in the region of 75 to 80% likelihood that this happens in the
amount of times I've
seen this exact model on a weekly. So that's the first thing, right? We're
expecting lower prices.
And then you come into the daily. And again, the daily is the same thing, right
? The previous day,
the previous day wicks above and closes inside. And so I knew today was going
to be a bearish day,
right? With a, again, at a minimum, a 67% chance from a data perspective over
15 years,
but also meet understanding price. And so you add that on top again, you're
looking at more of a
60, 67% plus likelihood of it playing out. And so I'm expecting a lot of prices
. And so very,
very strongly, I'm expecting that the weekly is on a trade lower and that today
at least was
going to trade lower. Now I, this is the best thing about, you know, partials
and trade management
and stuff like that is I've already piloted out my position. So I've already
won by not
trying to buy today and instead selling anything else that comes if we do end
up hitting these
lows, which again, I do think we could if we do end up hitting these lows, then
it's just another
win for me, right? And so if we now go into the 15 minute timeframe, knowing,
you know,
knowing what we know, we can see another thing as well is that this 15 minute
structure is so
huge, right? If you actually just zoom out of price and you look at things that
I want to
overcomplicate this too much, but look at how bearish price is, we have a retr
acement back up
into this old level and we start selling off this in here. Like I said, the
market sometimes,
when you price is going down, it's always the change of character. Remember
that when prices
coming down, sometimes your logic might not be the logic of the market.
Sometimes we think it's high,
low, lower, high, low, low, low, high, low, lower, higher, high, our with
bullish. So we sell here,
we buy here with wrong and wrong. Okay, low, low. Okay, now we're back.
When actually the market didn't see like that, the market seen it as high, low,
high, right,
low, retracement back into this old range, and then continuation sell off. That
's a very real
occurrence. We've just seen it before. We're seeing it again now and it's
always a change
of character. And again, that doesn't mean the change of character is incorrect
. The change
of character is extremely powerful. That's not what we're seeing here. If we go
to, let's say,
for example, a one-hour timeframe, which bear in mind, this isn't something
that I typically do.
I'm just using it just to demonstrate quite simply. We can see the actual one-
hour time frame is
extremely bearish. All right, we have the one-hour time frame that's aggressive
sell off, pull back,
aggressive sell off, pull back, and aggressive sell off. But no, take into
consideration this.
This is the big emphasis here. It's not about the hourly time frame that will
confuse you.
It's not about that. It's about the daily and weekly bias. It's about that
there is a very high chance
that this week trades lower and that today trades lower. And because of that,
because it's so
clear and obvious, this is a day where I can come into the market the same as I
did yesterday, right?
In fact, I'll pull it up right now. Probably it was in the live trading floor.
This is one day ago. It is my humble opinion that looking for longs is a bad
play. I will take
New York today, right? In here, 10 hours ago, if you were on live yesterday,
look at where
you're sold off from. For me, I am still highly convinced of my short bias,
regardless of M15
structures. This is already before I had even taken this trade. I was highly
conviction on shorts
and how price played out. The sweep that I needed to see and now we're selling
off.
And you can see this year, looking for longs is a bad play. I'm saying this at
this point in time,
right? Looking for longs and expecting price to hold through to these swing
highs, which is
what the model would be, is a bad play. If you try to long in here, you're
going to end up taking
at the best case scenario break even. And that's because of this contextual
understanding of
the direction of bias. And like I said, this is probably the, if any video I
could create,
this would be the most valuable. Because yeah, it's just there will be times
where
you've missed great opportunities because you were fixed on the indicator. And
again,
by all means, I say this to a lot of people, like, look, you are more than
welcome to just
follow and only follow market structure. And I, with a very high degree of
likelihood,
you will make money, right? Providing that you're obviously trading correctly
and emotions are
involved. If we're just looking purely from a technical perspective, you are
going to have a
lot of success with the indicator itself, just by playing out and following the
bias of just the
indicator itself. But if you want to become an advanced trader, and you know,
over time,
you want to be able to decipher. Maybe I should avoid looking for this today.
And it avoids losses
and things of that nature. The two main ones are going to be Asia highs and
lows at swing points,
especially when it's internal. And by far, strong directional bias conviction
when the both weekly
and daily are heavily against us. Meaning we have 15 years of data that's
saying that there's a
good chance that we're going to trade into this lower down here. Of course, I
want to trade with
that flow. And that's why I'm trying to do. And so, yeah, that would really be
my logic for
invalidation of structure. Don't be wrong. And I upset at the time I'm
following my structure.
But that 10% are able to make money by understanding context. Hopefully you
enjoyed that one.